[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat un salarié du privé
sur 4,7 en vue prescrire un arrêt
maladie en 2018 et à renoncer de façon
partielle ou totale
le premier ministre edouard philippe
s'est dit ouvert au télétravail pour
freiner l'augmentation des arrêts
maladie notamment pour une reprise en
douceur après une longue absence
le télétravail un mode d'organisation
qui permet de travailler en dehors des
locaux de son employeur une solution
pour répondre aux arrêts maladie c'est
le débat du jour avec nous un plateau ce
soir pour en parler valérie en trad
secrétaire d'actipôle 21 vous
accompagner le développement du
télétravail en france notamment par le
biais des espaces de coworking et sonia
porot vous êtes la secrétaire
départementale de la cgt des yvelines
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau en soit vous l'avez entendu le
premier ministre edouard philippe se dit
favorable au télétravail
il permet aux salariés de travailler
hors des locaux de l'entreprise
le télétravail peut être mis en place
dans le respect de certaines règles dès
l'embauché du salarié ou par la suite le
but et demi ni de minimiser les arrêts
de travail
un gouffre financier pour l'assurance
maladie vous ne craignez pas en tant que
représentante de la cgt que ce
dispositif favorise une pression exercée
sur l'employé afin qu'il travaille à son
domicile pour nous on n'est pas du tout
opposée à la cgt un côté des travail
mais pas comme
un mode de substitution à des arrêts
maladie ou à des droits qui peuvent
exister dans l'entreprise comme les
congés pour enfant malade va si on est
arrêté
c'est qu'on a besoin de se reposer de se
soigner
donc c'est pas c'est pas pour nous une
solution et s'il ya une augmentation des
arrêts maladie peut être qu'il faut
regarder justement l'organisation du
travail ou la charge de travail où les
conditions qui font que va par le temps
de transport peut faire que des salariés
obligés d'habiter de plus en plus loin
de leur lieu de travail oui peuvent
aspirer au télétravail et peut-être que
ça ça surprend le prenne dans sa
globalité mais pointer les salariés les
salariés malades on trouve ça plutôt
choquant parce que en 2010 est l'
enveloppe consacrée aux indemnités
journalières a atteint 7 milliards
d'euros pour un total de 7,4 millions
d'arrêt maladie prescrit donc justement
le télétravail c'est peut-être la
solution ça peut se pratiquer de deux
façons chez soi mais également au sein
des espaces de coworking valérie entre a
justement vous êtes la secrétaire donc
je les ai dit tout à l'heure d'actipôle
21 vous prenez le télétravail par le
biais des espaces de coworking
et ça ne cesse de s'accroître oui oui
c'est un marché en forte croissance
on a notamment vu une particulière
augmentation entre 2011 et 2015 est une
période à laquelle d'ailleurs avec
plusieurs espaces de coworking et des
différents représentants du télétravail
en france nous avons co conçu un label
un label qui s'appelle c3 et pour centre
collaboratif connectés et donc qui
permet de rassurer les entreprises et
les salariés sur le fait qu'ils vont
pouvoir télé travailler dans un lieu
professionnel en venant dans un espace
de coworking et le télétravail ça à
plusieurs enjeux économiques
environnementales et sociales
je vous propose de regarder ce que
pensent les yvelinois de ce nouveau mode
de travail
l'inconvénient c'est que ça ça vaut
quand même ça me contre 1 quand même à
travailler chez vous et généralement
quand on travaille chez soi et bien il
ya plus d'horaires moins de temps dans
les embouteillages et
et être plus efficace sur le travail
niveau de transport ça peut être
avantageux parce que personnellement
quand j'ai quand je vais travailler je
dois prendre plusieurs heures de train
tout ça donc c'est assez stressant j'ai
pas d'ordinateur pas d'internet rien je
suis contre site est bloqué chez toi
aussi tu as un certain handicap
du coup ça paraît comme le travail et
j'aimerais beaucoup le faire mais moi je
travaille en crèche
donc ça va compliquer mais mon conjoint
je sais que lui il en a
il sent il en fait et c'est hyper
pratique du coup ça lui permet de faire
des journées beaucoup plus importante
est d'être un peu plus je pense
constructif et dans son travail
on n'a pas à se déplacer du coup on a
moins de frais à payer pour tout ce qui
est des placements etc et essence et du
coup peut-être que travailler dans une
atmosphère entre guillemets familiale du
coup travail à la maison peut être plus
propice aux l'efficacité on l'a entendu
pour beaucoup le point positif du
télétravail c'est la réduction la
réduction du stress et l'amélioration
des qualités de vie une étude ifop
révèle que 39 % des arrêts maladie est
liée de près ou de loin au contexte
professionnel troubles psychologiques
pression ou encore épuisement avec le
télétravail donc moins de stress sur le
salarié mais aussi pour l'entreprise
avec une amélioration de la qualité du
travail et des bénéfices que vous avez
pu constater auprès des salariés oui oui
sont extrêmement importants c'est vrai
que le fait de gagner du temps dans les
transports c'est plus de temps avec la
famille donc
ou alors aussi pour de l'engagement ça
pète de l'engagement citoyen des
pratiques associatives de le sport aussi
qui participe aussi à l' équilibre donc
il ya tout de suite un bien-être chez le
salarié tous les toutous ce qui était
cité la baisse des coûts également la
baisse la baisse du stress si les
conditions de travail évidemment au
domicile sont évidemment professionnel
est propice justement un travail
seraient évidemment qu'il faut dans sa
globalité par exemple où il peut y avoir
du coup l'absence de ton de trajet et
les coûts qui vont avec
mais si c'est pas encadrées et la
majorité du télétravail aujourd'hui se
fait de façon informelle et ben c'est le
salarié qui payent l'électricité qui
paye l'ordinateur qui a pas forcément
une chaise et un bureau adapté et c'est
ce qui peut conduire à des problèmes de
santé comme des troubles musculo
squelettiques et puis après il faut voir
est-ce que c'est du télétravail à 100%
ou est ce qu'il ya un retour à
l'entreprise parce qu'il peut y avoir un
risque d'isolement de
absent du collectif de travail et ça
c'est aussi un élément extrêmement
important dans le travail
alors justement le salarié qui effectue
le télétravail chez lui est ce que à
terme cet isolement
c'est pas dangereux pour le salarié à
six mois j'ai été dans une entreprise de
relations clientèle qui a testé du
travail à 100% à domicile et les
quelques volontaires qui a eu une très
très vite demandé à revenir sur sur les
plateaux d'appels
parce que on a besoin d'échanger avec
ses collègues et ça fait partie du
travail et de la vie et de la vie
sociale et ça c'est un c'est un décès un
des risques
même s'il existe aussi en dehors du
télétravail on a parfois des entreprises
où on peut bosser sur un projet avec des
gens qui sont dans d'autres dans
d'autres sites avec très peu de moments
de rencontre mais les isolements est un
vrai risque est un vrai poids pour les
salariés au bout d'un certain temps
alors autre aspect prônée par les
télétravailleurs
il prône un gain de temps et des
économies considérables notamment sur le
carburant surtout en ce moment avec la
hausse des prix du carburant un
francilien sur trois mais plus de 45
minutes pour se rendre à son lieu de
travail
c'est beaucoup la mobilité donc c'est
une des principales préoccupations des
salades des salariés et c'est pourquoi
ils choisissent finalement le
télétravail vous pensez c'est c'est une
d une des raisons mais après encore une
fois c'est ça vient des choix
d'implantation des entreprises
quand les entreprises concentrent leurs
services au même endroit plutôt que
d'avoir plusieurs plusieurs sites plus
proches quand les prix des logements
près des lieux de concentration des
entreprises d'un grimpe les salariés
s'éloigne pour ce pour se loger
donc il ya aussi une responsabilité là
dessus des des entreprises
à ce niveau là et ça c'est aussi c'est
aussi à pointer dans la mise en oeuvre
du télétravail et avec une journée en
télétravail le salarié ne se déplace pas
donc moins de possibilités d'accidents
de travail mais l'employeur ne peut pas
vérifier ce que fait le salarié pendant
ses jours en télétravail il ne contrôle
plus le temps de travail mais les
résultats finalement mais c'est vrai que
quand on est en télétravail
la logique c'est plutôt d'être sur une
relation de confiance et de
responsabilisation des salariés et donc
du coup bien deux c'est aussi au rôle du
manager la responsabilité elle est vrai
aussi chez le mâle a duré c'est saristes
aussi au manager via des points
réguliers avec le salarié de s'assurer
que il est dans dé bonnes dispositions
des faits qui ne souffre pas d'isolement
de stress d'amplitude horaire parce
qu'il ya quand même des risques à
télétravailler à la maison donc il faut
quand même observer observer ces risques
le télétravail il peut conduire au maire
à des dérives mais qu'on assiste avec
l'ensemble des outils des outils
numériques
des fois c'est peut-être l'envers c'est
les séries sont trop connectés drew
surveiller au travers de leurs
ordinateurs de leurs mains de leur
téléphone portable d'un certain nombre
d'applications selon selon le métier
qu'on fait et il ya le risque de passer
à une espèce de disponibilité permanente
qui fait qu'il ya plus de temps de repos
qu'on n'a jamais avoir à la tête
l'esprit libre de son travail
et ça aussi c'est c'est quelque chose de
compliqué à à prendre en compte et c'est
pour ça que le télétravail il ya besoin
de négociations qui vend cadres dans les
entreprises même si c'est pas
obligatoire et que ça se passe pas juste
en tête à tête entre le salarié et
l'employeur
alors justement le salarié est toujours
très connecté
quand il est en télétravail certains
vont jusqu'à prendre leur téléphone dans
les toilettes de peur de se faire
appeler est ce que ce n'est pas parce
qu'il existe une mentalité française
valorisant la présence physique en
france il y a une forte culture du
présentéisme si je puis dire c'est juste
et oui le principal problème culturel du
télétravail il est il est là il est sûr
sur ce présentéisme le fait d'avoir ces
ressources à côté de soi en fait et du
coup il faut c'est pour ça qu'il faut en
parler avant c'est toujours mieux quand
le télétravail se passe en échange avec
les salariés et pas seulement avec les
salariés de tête j'ai tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait de décider de
zurich des groupes de salle rit et avec
les partenaires sociaux en effet ça se
passe d'autant mieux parce que ça permet
de de prévoir un certain nombre de
questions qui vont se révéler puis de
pouvoir échanger sur les risques alors
évidemment c'est pour ça que nous on
prône chaque tippl 21 le télétravail
dans les espaces de coworking parce
qu'on est bien identifié tous ces
risques et vous avez bien fait d'ajouter
le risque d'hyper connexion en effet
parce qu'il faut que le salarié puisse
se déconnecter et et puis aussi dissocie
vie professionnelle et vie personnelle
et que son domicile puissent rester
quand même un lieu de ressourcement
parce que savoir un lieu de repos et
pour ça qu'on encourage d'ailleurs le
recours dans les espaces de coworking
pour traiter la plupart de ces freins le
télétravail c'est aussi un enjeu
environnemental grâce au télétravail
on se déplace moins donc ça diminue les
trajets
domicile travail donc moins
d'embouteillages et par la même occasion
une baisse des émissions de co2 on
estime que si une personne qui réside à
25 kilomètres de son lieu de travail
passe deux jours par semaine en
télétravail
elle économise 112 litres d'essence par
an soit 2 tonnes de carbone en moins
dans l'atmosphère
le télétravail est la réponse aux
problèmes de mobilité n'ont cessé un
outil encore une fois à utiliser de
manière
de manière encadrée mais mais il y en a
il y en ad'autres on en a déjà cité un
devin de pouvoir aussi avoir des lieux
de travail à voir son entreprise qui a
des sites
voilà à proximité ça ça compte ça compte
aussi
et puis c'est aussi les choix
d'implantation des entreprises en europe
car qui était à 10 minutes de la gare de
saint-quentin quand ils ont mis leur
siège à voisins le bretonneux où c'était
plus accessible en transport des
salariés qui venaient en train se sont
mis à prendre leur voiture par exemple
donc ça ne règle ça ne règle pas tout je
le rappelle le télétravail est bien en
volontaires réversible et négociée entre
les deux parties le salarié et
l'employeur si des personnes qui nous
regardent souhaite mettre en place un
télétravail est ce que vous pouvez
rappeler les démarches à effectuer
auprès de son employeur
la première chose c'est simple on devra
de demander un entretien mais nous ce
conseil c'est de regarder par exemple le
guide pour négocier le télétravail qui
est sur le site de l'ugict cgt 1 qui
s'occupe notamment des ingénieurs cadres
et techniciens qui sont quand même les
plus concernés par ce mode
d'organisation du travail pour voir un
peu tous les points à prendre en compte
et puis bah ne pas hésiter à contacter
un représentant du personnel ou une
organisation syndicale
et si on veut faire du télétravail au
sein des espaces de coworking alors bien
souvent il faut je pense qu'il faut que
le salarié s'est le mieux en fait
identifier l'espace le plus proche de
celle vie celui qui va lui permettre du
moins de faire le moins de kilomètres
possibles et puis celui dans lequel il
va se retrouver dans un environnement
qui lui paraît le confortable pour lui
efficace professionnels donc après il
faut qu'ils en parlent en effet à son
manager il se rapproche des équipes des
équipes rh
après il ya plusieurs solutions qui
existent aussi pour les entreprises qui
peuvent faire ensemble de démarches
notamment parmi les partenaires d'haïti
peuvent intégrer une structure appelle l
bmg work lab qui accompagne les
entreprises dans l'ensemble des
démarches et qui justement prend le
temps d'écouter les salariés l'ensemble
des parties prenantes justement pour
faire en sorte que l'accord soit mis en
place et tienne bien compte des
particularités de l'entreprise sa
culture son organisation le llosa situ
des contraintes de réunion l'importance
du collectif aussi d'avoir des moments
où les personnes se retrouvent
merci mesdames c'est la fin de ce sept
huit débats très bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]